I'm very excited about this
year, 2018, my second year
at the University of Arizona.
We've been moving
people in all morning.
We've had a lot of our senior
leadership team and my cabinet
out, helping move in today.
Dana, thank you again
for inviting me back.
How many people were involved
in helping the students move in?
We have hundreds of students
and faculty and staff helping
move in.
We're moving in almost
68,000 students this week.
It's a community effort.
ROBERT: This is one of the
most academically accomplished
and gifted classes we've had in
many, many years, maybe ever.
We have 110 countries
represented, all 50 states.
31% of our students are
first generation students,
probably the highest number for
any of the 60 AAU universities
that we partner with.
Hi.
Hello.
I'm Bobby.
Hi.
I'm Kathryn.
Nice to meet you.
It's good to meet you.
I just wanted to
come by and say thank
you for choosing the U of A.
And what are you studying?
I'm a pre-business
marketing major.
Well, your mom
said, going to Eller.
Yeah.
Eller is fantastic.
I'm really excited.
Yes.
Student success is the key
part of the strategic plan.
And I'm just excited
about the class that's
come here this year from all
parts of the country and all
over the world to choose
the University of Arizona.
I think they made
a great choice.
You have to learn how to
do the Wild Cat thing.
You know, so, the way I--
so, OK but open it
up and it's a C. W C.
So that's a W and that's a C.
Yeah.
Bear down and go Cats.